bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette deuxième analyse de ces camps
se consacrer aujourd'hui à la course du
t-rex donc la course du t-rex au moment
où la jeep s'enfuit avec ian malcolm
elie sattler et robert 2012 et le t-rex
les poursuit
et justement cette course du t-rex elle
est très intéressant parce que ça colle
pas mal avec l'actualité
en effet vous avez peut-être vu passer
sur les réseaux sociaux la nouvelle
une nouvelle recherche qui démontrerait
que t-rex ne pouvais pas courir et vous
avez peut-être fait même partie de ceux
qui ont partagé cette nouvelle en étant
surpris d'apprendre que t-rex ne pouvais
pas courir puisque justement et bien
vous aviez vu dans jurassic park cette
fameuse scène de course ou le t-rex
rattrape quasiment une jeep sans trop
forcer et ben justement c'est le côté
sans trop forcer sur lequel on va
assister aujourd'hui parce que t-rex ne
pouvais pas courir ce n'est pas une
chose nouvelle ça fait au contraire très
longtemps qu on s'en doute pour une
simple et bonne raison le poids du t-rex
est estimé à 5 à 7 tonnes en fonction
des estimations ce qui est à peu près le
poids d'un éléphant or les éléphants ne
peuvent pas courir et eux ils ont quatre
pattes pour soutenir leur poids alors
que t-rex lille en a que deux donc c'est
au prennent deux fois plus de choc
s'il essaye de courir en tout cas déjà
quand il marche
ces eaux doivent supporter deux fois
plus de poids qu'un éléphant puisqu'il a
deux fois moins de membres
donc sachant que les éléphants ne
peuvent pas courir eux mêmes ne peuvent
pas galoper on ne s'attend pas à voir
courir un t-rex alors ça a quand même
été suggéré que t-rex pouvait courir
notamment par les tenant de la dinosaur
le nissan ce robert baker en premier
dans son livre le ptérodactyle rose
voire des grands théropodes tels que le
t-rex courir ça fait partie de ces
images percutantes qu'on voit dans ce
genre d'illustration mais il faut bien
admettre que la science derrière elle
est très spéculative et il y à de
nombreuses analyses qui ont été faites
et qui montre que non t-rex ne pouvais
pas courir plus de
25 km/heure que le t-rex n'était
certainement pas capable de faire mieux
que juste marcher vite
et justement dans cette scène de
jurassic park et bien c'est ce qu'on
voit en fait on ne voit pas t-rex courir
dans jurassic park
on voit t-rex marcher vite et tout ça ça
tient à la définition même de la course
la course c'est quand vos deux pieds ne
touchent pas le sol un moment du
mouvement
et si vous regardez bien la course du
t-rex
ce n'est pas une course en réalité il a
tout le temps au moins un pied au sol
contrairement à une autruche qui sprinte
contrairement à un émeu qui sprinte
contrairement à n'importe quel oiseau
coureur vous ne verrez pas à aucun
moment de la course du t-rex dans
jurassic park les deux pieds du t-rex se
décoller du sol
donc si vous faites partie justement des
gens qui sont surpris de voir que t-rex
ne courait pas eh bien c'est pas une
surprise en fait on le sait déjà et
c'était déjà dans le film jurassic park
s'était déjà suffisamment connue pour
être figurer dans le film jurassic park
en 1993 alors ce qui vous a peut être
induit en erreur c'est le fait qu'on a
chronométré le t-rex à 40 km heure donc
un peu plus rapide qu'un humain en
pleine course et du coup ça fait appel à
votre anthropocentrisme c'est à dire que
pour vous atteindre une vitesse de 30 à
40 km heure il faut courir pour ça où il
faut avoir un vélo mais pas pour le
t-rex le t-rex il a des jambes
suffisamment longue pour pas avoir
besoin de courir pour atteindre une
telle vitesse et comme je les dis plutôt
maintenant on pense plutôt qu'il allait
dans les 20 à 25 km heure plus tôt que
dans les 30 kg et 40 km heure mais on
explique tout ça en détail dans notre
vidéo sur le t-rex l'interview de jean
le loeuff qui nous a tous appris tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur le t-rex que je
vous mets en description si vous tenez à
aller la voir
mais ne soyez pas déçu et ne soyez pas
surpris de voir que le t-rex ne pouvais
pas courir ça n'a rien de nouveau et
c'est tout à fait logique
voilà merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
et je vous dis à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne